the bandit mentality it's about this
band-aid mentality most people live by
the band-aid analogy I've been talking
about this for many many years listen
I'm a Jamaica right now we brought a
couple hundred of our executives just at
this Moon Palace and one of my favorite
parts about these trips one of my
favorite part about these trips as the
late-night conversations favorite part
because it gets deeper last time I'm
having a conversation probably at about
1:00 o'clock 12:30 and one of the guys
I'm talking to you know everything that
I brought up first thing kept saying
well you know I'm just trying to make
sure that this is not gonna create
another conflict with this person or I
just want to make sure we're gonna be
good with this person for six months or
12 months or 18 months I just wanted to
be good I did listen every single thing
you look at in life you're looking at it
as a band-aid let me fix it with a
band-aid let me fix it with a band-aid
let me fix it with a band-aid let me fix
it with a band-aid some things you
cannot fix with a band-aid some things
you cannot you cannot fix a lot of
things with band-aid people have some
major health issues and their band-aid
mentality is I'll just take a Tylenol
you can't fix a home with a band-aid at
the top if rain comes your ceiling is
gonna get messed up you cannot fix a lot
of your business problems with a
band-aid you cannot you cannot fix your
marital problems with a band-aid some
marital issues are terrible you gotta go
still with the psychologist I'm figure
them out you cannot fix your health
be sure your wait the problem with a
band-aid oh let me drink you know such
and such oh let me take this pill or let
me do this I'm gonna lose 15 pounds
you can't pick a lot of things would
have been made and here's what happens
if you fix everything with a band-aid
fast forward a year from now two years
from now three years from now all of
those band-aids the wounds have gotten
bigger have gotten worse and now it's
gonna compound and you got to figure out
a way to fix all those band-aids that
you put up and I got to do 30 surgeries
na you lose momentum
like oh my gosh you just don't know what
I'm going through I'm having issues with
my marriage eliminations oh my hell I'm
having issues with my business and I've
been issues with my family in that issue
because you avoided conflict all these
years because everything to you was
about fixing it with a band-aid so as
you watch this video make a list what's
that one conversation I need to have
with a family member haven't had for a
while and I've been fixing it with a
band-aid what am I doing with my
marriage with my relationship trying to
fix everything with a bandit I you know
what we just try to avoid each other so
we don't fight you need to have that
conversation I don't want to get my
finances look because it's so terrible
if every time I look at you're depressed
no no you gotta take a look yet are you
gonna be 65 in no time I know this this
whole time about help make a list what
part of your health you're treating as
abandon your weight your bones what part
of it is it and then whatever list you
make one by one by one you gotta go
address them and create a solution for
them and in action I cuz I can guarantee
you all of those things you put
band-aids on eventually are gonna
compound into so many issues and then
one day you have so many issues you're
gonna murder you don't have time to go
pursue dreams and get stuck and sucked
in to all of these problems and then it
takes you 5 10 15 20 years to solve and
it's too late at that time to take a
moment
ask yourself what area do I put
band-aids on what can I do to fix them
and moving forward every single time you
solve a problem are you looking at it
from a short-term standpoint or
long-term is this a short-term solution
or a long-term solution Bank on long
term solution so you don't have dead
weights hanging around and it compounds
where you have to solve it 5 10 20 years
later
anyway have a great week everybody